I haven't come forth in a great many
years because I didn't want to be
relegated to another guest on a TV talk
show but I can assure you Satanism is
here to stay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and here we are for episode 56 and so 56
and hurricanes come
I know zero like we're recording this
show early it's actually Saturday yeah
and we're in Central Florida if you guys
didn't know so we're kind of bracing for
the impact of hurricane mo it'll
probably be tomorrow right
yes well yeah cuz we I'm easily get
blown away I know I don't think we'll
get blown away but for sure the power
will probably be out so I wanted to get
the show done and out of the way early
so I can get it uploaded so it'll go out
on time hopefully we'll be alright we've
we've already had one Dean McCaskill
already asked us he sent me a message
saying to be safe and I was like thanks
man yeah I know and I'm trying to get
that generator together I'm just waiting
for our TV to dry my hands know what I'm
talking about
our TV takes forever to cure hopefully
it'll be all right I mean you know like
do you know how we spent like the few
hours last night we were making like
pounds and pounds of like pasta
yeah boiled eggs and boiled chicken and
stuff like that just so if the power
goes out we can make like we have
classes I got propane but we won't have
electricity or planning not to have
electricity we probably have it cuz even
if it's not that bad day electricity
yeah and the ice makers can't make ice
fast enough yeah it's all kinds of stuff
that go wrong I know it's terrible but
well as long as the roof stays on yeah
and all the walls stay up the windows
stay on there hold the walls push all my
weight up against it like all the
motorcycles indoors yeah we have seen
the motorcycles are probably safer in
the garages because that's continents
all cinder block yeah true yeah but you
know by the time this show goes up we
still yeah this is like a biggest storm
in recorded history
and there's two more behind it yeah yeah
although I think one of them is little
on its head in Mexico so yeah so 190
mile an hour winds
yeah we'll see how it goes but anyway so
well today the show is gonna be about
Anton LaVey good ol Anton and this is
actually this is probably our most
requested topic yeah it's been requested
at least three times yeah I think so
so we're finally getting around to doing
it if you remember we did a show about
Aleister Crowley back on episode 24 yeah
so I think it was on that show that
everyone was like hey you do one way and
I was like all right I'll get around to
it so yeah well you know they're kind of
unrelated subject you know occult type
leaders or dark occult spiritualist or
something yeah but you know that time
was a lot different than grow it yeah
true but before we do that let's do our
regular shoutouts if you go to our
t-shirt store which is zazzle.com slash
13 o'clock I actually put I think I
mentioned on our escape from New York
movie review that I made like a snake
Plissken t-shirt yeah cool but I've also
made an Elizabeth báthory shirt yeah in
honor of our show about her so that's up
there too I'm gonna make some more in
the future I just haven't got around to
it yet but those two are new and they're
up there yeah there's all these shirts
look cool to you guys snap them up also
I want to mention our patreon page of
course if you want to go to that it's
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast if
you would like to donate to the show and
you don't want to do a monthly donation
then if you go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast.com wait 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com or something like
that you'll see it then there's a button
on there where you can do like a
one-time PayPal donation if you would
like to do that some people don't like
paper yeah and some people don't like
patreon or they don't want to do like a
monthly rolling donation which is
totally fine if you still want to donate
to the show then there's a PayPal
donation a little link on there we that
we actually got a new patreon
yeah you know I guess I am
boy we sure we could use some more
patrons yeah I have that many thing go
ahead wait yeah well you know they're
heavy lifters those supposed to go
paying $20 a month yeah we're gonna hook
them up we're gonna set up some cool
merchandise yeah actually on the 15th
which is this Friday hopefully if it's
still if our house is still standing
then I'm gonna be sending out some books
and autographs and yeah swag too are $20
patrons yeah so those will be mailed out
on the 15th so keep an eye out for that
and what else we're gonna put up a new
movie review there should be a new movie
review by the time this goes up there
should be another movie review up yeah
which will be an American Werewolf in
London yeah but yeah so that should be
up by the time this show goes up
hopefully also my new book the faceless
villain which is a true crime
compilation almost finished it's almost
finished yeah I have like only just a
tiny little bit left to do and then I
thought that I still have to do the
print layout but if it wasn't for the
storm probably didn't matter in a couple
days you'd have it up there yeah that's
why I was trying to get most of it done
like before the storm came and then I
got other work and stuff like that but
you know it should be done very soon and
like I said I don't see any reason why
it shouldn't be for sale by like
mid-october the list
maybe not the audiobook cuz that takes a
little bit longer but the print the
e-book should definitely be up by mid
October and maybe the audio book by that
to you changed the look of the title
card so the new movie reviews I think I
did yeah well cuz you complained yeah
yeah I thought it was boring with the
red curtains yeah it was okay you know
we did it so quickly yeah I just kind of
threw them together yeah but there's a
big difference now you look at those
title cards next to other movie reviews
on YouTube maybe pop yeah I mean I just
use like cool stills from the movie
generate and the lettering from the I
think actually I think we're getting
more new subscribers based on the movie
reviews than we did on the 13 o'clock in
minutes yeah quite disappointing because
what you put a lot of work into that
yeah and I'm still gonna do those it's
just they take a long time to do the
movie reviews are much easier yeah
because you know it's just like a simple
slideshow and we just I mean we've seen
most of the movies so we just kind of
shoot the [ __ ] more than our can demand
is people like movie retrospectives and
movie reviews yeah well that's why we're
concentrating more on doing those like I
said I'm still gonna do some of the 13
o'clock in minutes videos they just take
longer and I got some new cool blu-rays
everybody knows the flash Gordon's
coming yeah I got that blu-ray and when
it winter arrives and we're gonna do a
blue river view of action yeah I've been
wanting ideo Flash Gordon actually
because that movies a lot of fun these
new blue razor there's so much better
than the DVDs the colors pop a lot
better there's a lot more bonus material
but you know you know might like them
well gosh the John Carpenter movies that
we've got it's like there's so much
extra stuff on there that it's like it's
like in three movies yeah I mean I think
we just we didn't even get through all
the extra stuff nothing no it was like
hours and hours and hours no you can sit
there and watch the thing and have the
crustle tell you what it was like to
[Laughter]
watch some of the like special effects
we're gonna do a live also hey he just
got that on blu-ray and saw that new
Rambo now see we watched that last night
because you bought it right yeah cuz our
friend Matt hi Matt he recommended it
yeah Matt loves across the let us show
him the crustle on escape from New York
he had never seen it and he goes oh man
dude have you seen the new Rambo no no
movie come out I think it's like 2011 or
something okay because we were watching
Atlantic because I was pretty sure I'd
never seen it but we're watching it last
night I'm like I've seen this [ __ ]
movie it had over top gore it was very
gory yeah but that's why I remember like
I didn't remember that I'd seen it until
we started watching it and then I'm like
wait a second I've seen this before I
don't know how or under what
circumstances I would have seen it
unless I saw it with you I liked it
alright yeah I don't think
probably not oh all right well there
isn't much to it other than limbs flying
everywhere people getting blown up by
landmines yeah kind of respect to still
overdo it though you know yeah he
directed that and I think you read he
wrote a lot of yeah he co-wrote it was
almost kind of like a an independent
film yeah I don't know if they made
money but it's pretty cool yeah a
shoot-'em-up shoot some of the CGI like
was yeah the blast G yeah but you know
other than that it was it wasn't alright
yeah like I said I was I was watching I
was like I'm sure I've seen this [ __ ]
movie before but I don't know a lot of
people taking little samples of the
seeds and put them in today we're
talking about Anton LaVey
you kind of talking about I don't know
we're just kind of shooting this [ __ ]
about him in general yeah he seemed like
sort of a fascinating character much
like Alistair Hurley was I think Crowley
took it more serious yeah curly believed
it I think yeah I think he really did
moist yeah I don't think Anton LaVey did
no I think it's working yeah I think it
was he was cool he was a showman yes he
was very PT Barnum's I guess and he
didn't deny that he said that's part of
Satanism yeah he called it the lesser
magic I remember he's the lesser a
greater magic I think he called it
lesser magics pen along to us I've read
the book he wasn't being deceptive no he
did admit that he was a liar yeah he did
that he made a lot of things object that
you would never you know very
entertaining guy yeah but like I said
much like curly there's so much legend
and myth and stuff like that surrounding
him a lot of him generated by himself
that you know in later years like after
he died you know people came forward and
said no that wasn't true or you know
various people that investigated him
like probably from his early life how he
explained like getting into Satanism and
stuff like that was that oh he left high
school and went to join the circus or
the carnival and that he worked as a
cage boy yeah lion lion tamers that type
of thing and they organ
yeah you played like the organ in the
Calliope and so I okay so he said that
he got the idea the chord sort of kernel
of the idea of starting Satanism so he
says because when he joined the carnival
he said you know I saw the same people
coming out and watching all the
burlesque shows and all the all the
stuff at the carnival and then you'd see
them Sunday in the revival tent you know
he's in Jesus and all this other stuff
so he saw like the hypocrisy of religion
pretty much is that's what he said and
that's kind of what encouraged him to
get away from religion or organized
religion and start he ended up making
that unreligious basically yeah
based on philosophies that had already
existed well actually pretty much like
Friedrich Nietzsche well and honestly
and I'll probably bring this up later
but a lot of the stuff that's in the
Satanic Bible and stuff like that some
of it he stole word-for-word from a
white supremacist screed from 1896
called white is right by Ragnar Redbeard
they don't know who that person was you
know it was like a pseudonym but yeah it
was sort of this really scary like this
racist yeah yeah but the thing is Anton
LaVey because he was Jewish I'm guessing
that when he wrote The Satanic Bible
he's like oh well I like some of the
ideas from might is right the more
libertarian type of ideas but he didn't
like all the racism and proto fascism
and stuff like that that was in there so
he got rid of all that and sort of
replaced it with esotericism like
philosophical medicine that he stole
from like John Dee's like knocking keys
and all that kind of stuff but like I
said some of the some of the stuff
that's in the Satanic Bible was taken
word-for-word from - right well he like
he liked to panache yeah - right
probably had some pretty good pretty
cool passages in it
yeah sounded good yeah it was like some
kind of Viking and stuff and you know
Levay himself said that it's your right
to steal things yeah basically if you
can steal it or if you can't flip an
idea around then you should if you like
it yeah that's part of your abilities so
there's nothing wrong
plagiarizing and stealing yeah and he
probably figured out the guys dead
[Laughter]
that's probably in the public domain
that anyway but well the thing is
levae like I said this stuff about him
joining the carnival and all that kind
of stuff there's really no evidence that
he had really ever joined the Carl
however when he was a little bit older
he wasn't organ player and played the
Calliope and things like that and you
know he moved out to he lived in San
Francisco he was actually born in San
Francisco and then later he went to LA
and he was able to get jobs at
nightclubs and stuff like that playing
the organ and whatnot and in various
burlesque houses now there's also a
legend - I think that he came up with
that he had an affair with the then
unknown Marilyn Monroe when she was a
burlesque dancer at the Mayan theater
huh now this has been denied by pretty
much a puppet because everyone says for
one thing the Mayan theater was never a
burlesque theater and for another thing
Marilyn Rose had never danced there so
you know he probably made that up also
yeah I don't think he Marilyn Monroe no
one else it was yeah it was calling for
him to make up stories like I said
that's why it's kind of hard and like
curly it's kind of hard to get to the
bottom of because he was he was really a
really good self promoter yeah so he
would just make things up like I said he
never denied that really I was he even
said that in his biography yes you would
make up all these stories you're like
yeah I'm a liar that's what Satan does
yeah that's part of his magic yeah yeah
so then he claims after that whole thing
happened then he claims that he went
back to San Francisco and then he says
that he worked I think he worked as like
a crime photographer for the San
Francisco Police Department I think he
might have in some capacity he also said
he worked as a psychic investigator
which I think was kind of yeah all right
I can buy that right I he might have
been like a freelance yeah psychic
investigator he said that the San
Francisco Police Department referred him
some cases like psychics
now some police departments do use
psychics I don't think they like that to
be yeah publicize necessary
was possible yeah I guarantee there
wasn't much to that no I don't think so
like it's like I said some of it might
be true but he probably like exaggerated
yeah kind of during this time when he
was into all this you know psychic
investigation and occult interest and
stuff like that
he kind of made friends with like a lot
of horror sci-fi type writers like a lot
of writers that worked for Weird Tales
magazine and stuff like that like Clark
Ashton Smith and people of that nature
so he kind of got into those sort of
circles yeah you know he got married he
was he eventually ended up married once
or twice but he had like a bunch of
different girlfriends he had some kids
and Zeena is probably the most famous
one because she was on that overall
their show yeah good-looking woman I
think we talked about her a little bit
on that show that back in episode 2 when
we did satanic panic and even though she
was kind of into the church for a long
time it was like a representative of
after he died she kind of renounced him
and yeah when an opposite way there were
allegations after he died that he had
been abusive and I don't know toward her
or toward her mother or whatever because
he was never married to her mother
although they were together for 25 years
Anton was a good showman but basically
what he was used to scenester a lot of
the stuff a lot of the stuff did you
could really only get away with it if
you were in the right social seat right
yes yeah I think it definitely helped
that he was kind of in with all these
other sort of psychic investigators
these sort of you know sci-fi writers
and he kind of because he played Oregon
and LA nightclubs and stuff like that I
guess he kind of got in with a little
bit of the Hollywood scene and stuff too
and you know he started having parties
and like more and more famous people
would I think there was a claim that he
had he knew Manson
Charles Mintz yeah yeah so I understand
that he may have known Charles Manson to
her at least Metis yeah I'm not sure and
I might get a little bit more into that
later but I'm not sure if he knew
Charles Manson but he pretty much it's
pretty much for sure that he knew Susan
Atkins okay yeah so I might talk about
that a little bit later but you know the
Beach Boys knew Charles Manson everybody
knows that one dude said yeah he's
pretty good
he could play yeah didn't they well I
thought they
some of the songs yeah I don't like
don't quote me on that but I'm pretty
sure I heard that yeah they bought some
of his songs like before he went off
serial killer II yeah and actually it
was a - ooh a killer though well he was
like the mastermind yet so made people
be serious yes
yeah it's funny because his the
association between Satanism and Anton
LaVey and Charles Manson was one of the
things that kind of made a lot of people
run away from the church you know I mean
after 1969 sorrowful or it was a fad you
know it definitely was I definitely
think you know in the mid 60s
you know and I think we talked about
this too on the satanic panic show that
people were becoming disillusioned with
traditional religions and stuff like
that silver you know all the hippies and
stuff they were looking for other stuff
new age type religion and so it seems
like Anton LaVey came along at just the
right time the right place right time
the right character and personality and
you know [ __ ] so he felt like when
people would go to his house and go to
the park go to parties with him yeah it
would become st. Cygnus jr. yeah Sammy
Davis jr. yeah he was in it for a while
yeah yeah if used to watch the
Cannonball Run he's dressed as a priest
and he's wearing the little satanic
church back head of bathroom it does he
have the one red fingernail monkey
finger now I'd have to see that I
haven't I saw that movie a million times
I was girl but I haven't said it since
then but that was kind of one of their
little things where they hate their
pinky fingernail red and and apparently
he did that so yeah he was in there for
a while too now the Church of Satan was
founded of course or so he says
on June 6 1966 which in you know
Rosemary's Baby was conceived he called
it the Year yr1 yes Anna say Tanis or
whatever it was like I said ever the
ever the showman ever the PT Barnum kind
of thing and he also said that our
little kitten keeps running their
freedom that's why you keep airing the
dark actually yeah she figured out of it
anyway and she keeps coming in to be
like what are you guys doing in here
okay yeah that door doesn't really uh
yeah she pees pushing the door I gotta
fix it yeah you should
but yeah so he claims that June 6 1966
he proclaimed it year when he's like I'm
gonna shave my head and I'm gonna start
a satanic cult now later on his wife or
girlfriend at the time said well he
actually shaved his head because I dared
him to or something it looks really cool
looks just like Max von Sydow from Ming
Ming the Merciless yeah and he actually
has been compared to you yeah but yeah
like I said there were actually like a
lot of because it wasn't you know it was
kind of a hip thing to be in the Church
of Satan yeah because the Church of
Satan they weren't really religious I
mean even from their founding I don't
think they were meant to be they didn't
really believe in the devil they didn't
believe in demons they didn't believe in
anything any supernatural entities no it
was kind of more about just being a head
of mystic individualistic thing that had
some kind of ritual on top of it just as
kind of a fun indulgent yeah I don't
look describe it as like a more stylish
version of atheism yeah and it actually
is an atheistic as most of the as it
still is now and so are the offshoot
group yeah they just used the devil and
the idea of the devil and Satan Patrol
Christians and like squares yeah just
because they know that people are afraid
of that type of thing and stuff like
that but it's actually kind of funny to
me because I had Bree I had never heard
any of Anton LaVey it's like he made a
couple albums and stuff like that
because you know he played the organ in
Calliope oh and this is an interesting
fact to Anton LaVey
as much as he is kind of named checked
by a lot of you know death metal bands
that he hated that kind of music didn't
know that hated that amusing he liked
old stuff he liked really old like you
know use it or old organ players because
he liked stuff from the 30s and stuff
like that
yeah he couldn't stand any of that have
you been alert I don't even think he
liked rock music particularly Marilyn
Manson went to go meet up with it yeah
that's true I think I have a picture of
Manson said the house was pretty shabby
yeah time and he was just like a regular
old guy yeah I bet you Anton do you know
who Marilyn Manson was he probably
didn't it seemed like most most of the
music that he liked was old sorry he
really didn't like any heavy metal or
anything like that yeah so like I said
when he formed the Church of Satan I
think some of the hippies have kind of a
darker pre-election we're kind of like
oh that's kind of a cool idea but I had
never heard any of Anton LaVey albums
because he made a couple and so when I
was researching this show I said well I
want like a little music snippet from
something or anything I don't think he's
sang but because most of it was
instrumental or there was a woman
singing on it it's funny to me because
it's very I think I said to you
yesterday is it's very Count Chocula
which I'm not sure if that was like
scary or like slicked out the squares at
the time but like now it's a in fact the
song that I have that I'm going to put
at the end actually reminded me of that
45 grade song the one about the vampire
a camera yeah but yeah but yeah that it
kind of reminds me of that like it's
very cartoony like a Disney Halloween
kind of special sort of music but uh so
not particularly frightening I don't
think but apparently a lot of people
were freaked out but you know not so
much of the 60s like I said they kind of
uh you know he got a lot of Hollywood
people to come to his parties and [ __ ]
like that
now he had a house called the Black
House yeah and he had all these big
parties there and he would have rituals
there you know probably one of the
reasons that his parties were so famous
was because he would have these kind of
black mass ceremonies with naked ladies
and they'd be acting as the altar and he
would have dancers and stuff yeah
someone filmed you know you can show
some yeah there's pictures of them all
over the place definitely putting on a
show and a day it would have tripped you
out but you look a very Alice Cooper
super type of thing like he would do a
little bit later like I said which I've
never understood why people found that
sort of thing
frightening or anything like that but
what a boy do I know but interestingly
one at one of his parties and actually
it might have been more than one but in
about 1967 he was having like a party
that he was just called the witches
Sabbath or whatever and he was like
looking around for women to dance naked
at it or dance topless rather and one of
these women was Susan Atkins now this
was two years before the Manson murders
okay and she was apparently a pretty
normal chick now she wrote a book later
which I didn't know where because she
found Jesus of course
and so she kind of wrote a book about oh
you know I was a devil worshiper and now
I found the light of love wow yeah but
but in that book she says that over the
course of like the rehearsals for this
party you know she was practicing their
dancin and all this other stuff she says
that her boyfriend at the time you know
said well I could see you changing like
that whole time that you were like so
she was like being taken over by the
dark side I don't know if she was trying
to like a lace of responsibility for her
later action by saying Anton LaVey put a
curse on me or some [ __ ] like that I
don't know if that's what she was saying
but she was saying that that's kind of
that was the start of her downfall that
led with her murdering several people
yeah it wasn't that no of course I like
I said that was just her kind of say oh
the devil made me do it drew it's just
in a more roundabout way but I'll tell
you what okay so we're at the halfway
point right now so we are going to take
a break right now and then when we come
back we will talk some more about it all
day
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but an easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we're back talking about Anton
LaVey now really the Church of Satan
it's kind of you know faddish Nisour
popularity or something like that really
didn't last much beyond 1969 it still
exists today obviously um after Anton
LaVey his death it was taken over by
Peter H Gilmore who still runs it now
yeah and I recommend that guy he does
really good podcast Peter HD oh yeah
he's he's funny yes so he's the hi smart
too yeah but at the time probably I
think probably the best other than you
know the writers that were in the group
and Sammy Davis jr. and stuff like that
I think his best-known association
Hollywood wise was with Jayne Mansfield
now Jayne Mansfield probably best known
I don't know if young girl Istres know
she is an even think she does very very
popular 50s blonde bombshell type of she
posed for Playboy that's kind of how she
got famous she was in a couple movies
include probably her most famous one as
the girl can't help it which actually we
just watched revealed last night she
would kind of a Marilyn Monroe type but
much more you know full up she was like
much she liked big huge tits and okay
stuff like that you know man feel she
was a kind of a flash in the pan I guess
she was really only famous for a few
years I think she got famous in the late
50s and then by the time early nice hour
he was like yeah she seems like a cool
[ __ ] I was wondering I've seen a couple
of other movies that she was in and she
seems she seems like a cutie pie you
know by the time the early 60s rolled
around she was kind of her fame was kind
of on the wane and apparently I don't
know if she got associated with the
Church of Satan as a sort of gimmick or
because she thought it would make her
seem edgy or she wanted to do something
kind of controversial rather but by all
accounts she and Anton LaVey were
actually really good friends okay she
spent a lot of time at his house he
would come to her house which was called
the Pink Palace and had a heart-shaped
pool she had a little chihuahua the
whole deal she was very you know what I
mean she was kind of one of those type
of girls but apparently she was much
smarter than she seems she was just kind
of played her because she thought that's
what people wanted so heard Anton LaVey
we were pretty good friends now
apparently her boyfriend that
time she was married three times she
didn't have a real super happy life but
her boyfriend at the time of her
association with Anton LaVey
was evidently super jealous he didn't
really and he thought the whole Anton
LaVey see that something was stupid yeah
and you know when they would come over
to Anton LaVey house he would like laugh
at all of this right you know he would
like you know do that kind of crap now
the legend goes that Anton LaVey put a
curse on this person I don't know what
his name is Ross something I want to say
I had it here but I don't so he
supposedly put a curse on him that's
what the legend goes now a little while
later obviously if you know anything
about Jane Mansfield him and her and one
other guy that were in this card this
coat that was a car accident and they
the three adults were killed right her
children were also in the car but they
all survived I think the perception is
that Jane Mansfield was decapitated that
is not the case that it was actually
just her wig they are and if came off
and went into the windshield or was kind
of stuck in the windshield so she was
not decapitated but there was like a lot
of rumor around that time that Anton
LaVey skirts had killed her as well
right
like because it was trying to get him
right she's friendly fire but yeah so
like I said I don't know if that's true
that's kind of the only thing I there's
kind of different cases about it because
there's some where he said that the guy
like lit a candle like in his house yeah
and Anton LaVey was like don't like that
that's my cursing candle like I hope I
put it out in time or something like
that but then I don't know if if the
story changed or if just later he got
pissed at I was like all right [ __ ] you
I'm cursing you for real right
but apparently so the guy did get killed
like not too long after that okay so
like I said kind of a hip thing for a
few years mid to late 60s then the whole
Charles Manson thing happened and it
seems to me like the Manson murders were
kind of like the abrupt end of the
hippie era or you know that was earth
on too far yeah pretty much and because
Susan Atkins was one of the killers and
she had also been associated with Anton
LaVey and Charles Manson also had some
kind of similar ideas or you know
similar kind God and the devil on this
and that the other thing Charles Manson
was also kind of interested in
Scientology t1d briefly yeah briefly so
he so he liked all the [ __ ] systems
like that but yes tell us you know the
LA scene back in those days and like I
said it does seems like a lot of people
yeah and all the notable people all hung
out pretty much yeah I would hate to
cast aspersions cuz I don't want to be
one of those people like the people in
the 80s during the Satanic painters like
everybody that plays dumbed into dragons
as a Satanist probably because there was
so much of that [ __ ] going everybody was
getting into crazy New Age beliefs and
cults and stuff like that and 99.99%
those people didn't kill anybody or
didn't hurt anybody they just seven
weren't even serious no they just did it
for a few years for fun and they were
like okay well that was my wayward youth
right kind of thing and I think a lot of
people that got involved in Satanism
same kind of thing the nightclubs
weren't as good back then so you had to
do something well yeah that's true my
clubs didn't really become good to the
disco era I think that's actually
probably a more controversial schoo that
was the beginning of the modern well it
was very it was the beginning of the era
where the nightclub was like was the
center of a slight end all be all yes
you know like I said I would probably
say yeah disco probably started though
yeah as much and then everybody got
their own version of that yeah
many have you all in the early any
chance I was no romantic you know with
all the stuff in England about the South
you know I think I think it was kind of
like disco that brought that to the main
yeah you're probably right about that to
the mainstream yeah
there you know New York had it had a
punk on the ground seen before that you
get off-topic but yeah but really disco
brought the idea of the nightclub I
think as a as a center of a social scene
to the mainstream yeah but how long are
you gonna run just go for you know yeah
you need lots of cocaine you run disco
and by the 80s they can all run out yeah
yeah like you said in the 60s I guess
they're you know people would have house
parties or they have stuff like that and
so you had to do something different
I suppose it's like oh let's do Satanism
let's have people dressing which capes
yeah you know with with their boobies
hanging out and like touch each other
with swords and have all kind of like HP
yeah and most of those people are gone
now yeah they moved to other parts of
the United States long story
well the thing and the thing Tube like
before we go on to something else was
that Jayne Mansfield you know despite
being hanging out with a holiday and she
would like go out to dinner with him and
so if there were rumors that they you
know had an affair but you know that's
not substantiated she proclaimed all
throughout her life that she was a
Catholic and she didn't believe in
Satanism and all that other kind of
stuff but like I said they just didn't
believe in sickness didn't believe in
Satanism either it was just kind of all
a show I think it still is we can talk
about what its tenets are we have that
yeah so what you know what's the thing
about the Church of Satan
now like I said he's stole a great deal
of ideas from velocities and
philosophies you know like he said
Nietzsche Sultan Superman brand
you know that type of social darwinism
type ideas and that kind of things that
we're going on back then and then he
kind of added a layer of esotericism and
philosophy on top of it but at its core
it's pretty much it's an individual it's
a little nihilistic - I would think but
it's more just like an individualistic
philosophy that basically just says it
describes man as man is or how they
believe man is yeah I agree with most of
what they're saying actually okay so the
Church of Satan officially has nine
satanic statements yeah they're not
Commandments not Commandments these are
the truth and they also have nine
satanic sins which we'll get to in a
minute but the nine satanic statements
famously are one Satan represents
indulgence instead of abstinence and
what they're talking about is you know
most most of your religions they're
saying they're asking you to abstain
from pleasure yeah well in this system
they're saying that that's kind of dumb
abstain why there's basically they're
saying there's no afterlife so there's
no reason yeah a theistic philosophy so
you know it's there's not it's not kind
of a course of you know and the next one
which is number two Satan represents
vital existence
instead of spiritual pipe dreams yeah
they're talking about you know living in
the here now right of some you know
fantasy future something's gonna happen
after you died or wherever
number three Satan represents undefiled
wisdom instead of hypocritical
self-deceit yeah they're saying that you
know it's better to know the truth
instead of buying into this [ __ ]
that you'd read in religious right
number four Satan represents kindness to
those who deserve it instead of love
wasted on ingrates
what they're saying there is basically
you know only worry about people who are
good people don't worry about bad people
yeah people that you know aren't worth
anything to you because they're dumb or
just bad you know
number five Satan represents vengeance
instead of turning the other cheek then
with what they're saying is that
sometimes you gotta slap
[Laughter]
today's term you know you better better
handle your business if somebody does
you're wrong you have to pay them back
number six Satan represents
responsibility to the responsible
instead of concern for psychic vampires
yeah it kind of goes back we don't want
to yeah just worry about so a lot of
these are kind of say me yeah they're
kind of save number seven Satan
represents man as just another animal
sometimes better more often worse than
those who walk on all fours who because
of his divine spiritual and intellectual
development that partisan quote has
become the most vicious animal of all
yeah they're just saying you know we're
animals like the rest of the animals and
because we're smart we can really put
some put a hurtin on things yeah we can
really think of some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
perhaps a honey badger would not right
yes number eight Satan represents all of
the so-called sins as they all lead to
physical mental or emotional
gratification there was actually certain
schools of Christian thought that yeah
thought that that you in order to reach
salvation you had to commit sins yeah to
commit sins and know what sins are and
then yet be absolved of those sins so
you could transfer transcend transcend
them which is actually a pretty good way
I mean that if there was only a choice
of two Christian cults where one said
you can have you can't have pi and the
other one said you can have pi if you
ask for forgiveness after you eat the
pie then I know which was big into that
that's how we got in girls pants so you
know it would have solution is like yeah
well that sounds legit that way you can
see Lindsey you can choose good you have
to know evils makes more sense to me
than listening to some crap from
somebody that's never done anything yeah
and has never gone through any [ __ ] or
anything like that like how the [ __ ]
would they know anything it's just kind
of like you know what I mean it's kind
of like in the old days when couples
would get marriage advice from some
crusty old dude whose surgeon yeah you
know
never been married yeah like what the
[ __ ] no okay what was that all right
number nine Satan has been the best
friend that church has ever had as he
had kept he has kept it in business all
these years yeah trolla which they still
do nowadays yeah so now only if you
really if you look at those nine
statements there's not a whole lot to
them that could be construed as unusual
yeah most of them aren't even really all
that controversial not anymore they're
not satanic by any stretch of the
imagination
they're and I don't think I mean I think
that sometimes cuz I don't know like I
feel like a lot of you know edgy
teenagers were into this back in the day
because I think they thought it sounded
like you know more edgy that was my
thinking sighs I think in the days that
was you know outside the window of what
was success that was yeah it was
probably outside the window well it was
outside the the window of acceptability
sure but nowadays that's that's just
kind of how things are yeah I don't
think anyone is foremost offended by
that anymore unless they're like super
fundamentalist or anything like that now
there are also nine satanic sins yeah
the sins are funny yes now the sins of
Satanism
number one is stupidity yeah that's a
sin which I agree with some of this yeah
they're basically saying you know
Satanist should see through you know
just see through people trying to
deceive them and see through [ __ ]
you know on the whole number two is
pretentiousness don't be stuck up which
is kind of funny cuz well I don't know
if I'd call Anton LaVey pretentious but
I think well I think curly was for
specialist at least Anton LaVey was like
yeah it's all [ __ ] well and time
like people that had you know pride and
yeah they do you had to back it up yeah
a person who is pretentious you know has
all this pride and it's unfounded yeah
he saw the number three satanic sin is
solipsism meaning projecting your own
beliefs or responses on to other people
assuming that other people is are the
same as you
Manit is a seeing yourself as the center
of the universe as a interpretation of
that yeah same type of thing
number four is self-deceit which is also
in the satanic statements but they
thought it was important enough to
double up on it
number five heard conformity yes pretty
self-explanatory yeah
number six lack of perspective you know
they say you must never lose sight of
who and what you are and what a threat
you can be by your very existence yeah
number seven forgetfulness of past
orthodoxies they're basically saying
don't forget all the [ __ ] that
happened back to us like don't fall for
the same [ __ ] again right like if
it's not you know so be aware of things
that have gone on before and don't fall
for the same stuff again
number eight counterproductive pride
yeah he didn't have anything against
pride per se as you said but you had to
have something to be proud of he didn't
like people who were yeah her like
overconfident when they didn't have
anything to back it up yeah if you had
inferior skills but then you're walking
around like you're proud as hell and you
know you don't have the right to the
pride and number nine lack of aesthetics
yeah bad tasted [ __ ] or being a slob
yeah I mean you know you had to kind of
go out look at your best and stuff like
that which you know we're in the goth
subculture so actually if you were to
look at hands on the Church of Satan and
everything in a way they were gone they
were preferred oh yeah it's the same
type of thing same type of thing
visually they were gods
yeah actually some of the attitudes were
they were there were times there were
some of the early goth scene like
specially the post-industrial goth they
were also Satanists you know like got
some death in June yeah current 93 they
had elements of Satanism now throughout
the 60s and 70s anton lavey he claimed
that he was on he was a consultant for
Rosemary's Baby he also said that he
played Satan during the rape scene yeah
which I really do which I which everyone
everyone on the crew of Rosemary's Baby
was like that no no however one movie he
was involved with was the devil's rain
starring John Travolta and the shot
really
see that one what was in that yeah
briefly he had like and he actually
wasn't that cuz I saw him okay
I haven't seen that movie in a long time
but I've seen write a review that one
yeah when I definitely have to do the
devil's rain it's uh I think Ernest
Borgnine wasn't it like but yeah I'm
pretty sure if I remember correctly he
was in The Devil's rain but yeah so
Anton LaVey actually wasn't that I think
he's in like one scene for like two
seconds or something like that you kind
of see him in the background but you
know as the 70s went on you know the
church started to fall apart after 1969
a lot of people well it didn't make left
yeah and it didn't make money Anson
started trying to make money off of it
by saying by doing a Scientology type of
thing and saying oh well you can obtain
the higher levels if you give me X
amount of dollars yeah and I think a lot
of people got pissed off at that realize
yeah you do that
yes and we'll see that's why the whole
religion of safety you're kind of
shooting yourself in the foot by telling
everybody hey think for yourself and be
individual yeah you threw [ __ ] funny
because then if you say yeah what did
you teach me well the house started to
fall apart
yeah black house you see photographs of
it it's the house is not very special
looking it's just normal sex weird
because every single almost every single
thing I've read about Anton LaVey the
the person that wrote the article felt
the need to call the house ugly it kind
of was I don't know it was but they were
all written at different times what they
often it was not a real expensive house
I mean you know don't don't expect to
see some kind of black mansion somewhere
on a manor would have been rats that
have been really cool no this is just
like a little it's not he wasn't like a
zillionaire yes
you didn't have any money it's like he
had a lot more notoriety than shag
carpeting
yeah shag carpeting it's like you've
read a bunch of books and had some
albums and stuff but it's like even at
its height I don't know how many copies
that book sold or how many copies this
album sold I mean that's a very niche
market yeah Satanism you know by the
time the 80s came around and you know
there's the whole satanic panic saying
and stuff so I feel like he maybe had a
little bit of a revival then but you
know at that point he was just kind of
like a boogeyman for the fundamentalist
right really it was my understanding
that you know like this heavy metal guys
and you know of course Marilyn Manson
some of those guys would go meet Anton
LaVey
yeah and they would get like the
official blessing give ads on any money
either no and like I said it's all
everybody knows just like hey these
long-haired Satan guys want to come see
you this is a picture taken
there's this guy out here named Vince
Neil yeah Tommy Lee no these guys nah
give him some street cred but you know
and then later on I think some [ __ ] came
out about Anton LaVey like some of his
wives girlfriends had like restraining
orders against him and things of that
nature so he might not have been as nice
a dude as well he never claimed yeah but
true he'd never de claimed to be a nice
day and say yeah that's fair enough but
like I said he had a bunch of kids what
three kids I think Cena is probably the
most famous like I said and he also has
a son named Satan Satan circ sees about
Michael Akeno yeah okay so like I said
if you saw a satanic panic show I think
we talked a little bit about him because
he was on the same yeah Geraldo show
actually no levae was actually a change
of mind we oughta talk about him last
what we should do is talk about Gilmore
and what happens with churches Satan and
then we can talk about yeah because
after Anton LaVey died the church was
taken over by Peter H Gilmore yeah and
they're still around now okay and they
still you don't really see as much
because I think people confuse them with
the Satanic temple which are the ones
that put those Baphomet statues like
like in protest like the troll you know
Christians that want to put such a
little unrelated factions anyone can
claim to be some kind of satanic Church
there's no you know like you know
there's no and honestly I think a lot of
these satanic churches like I said are
basically basically just trolling
organizations or people just want to
have people to hang out with it's a
philosophy and [ __ ] like that I've seen
it compared to like the Church of the
SubGenius where it's like not really a
Church in the sense that we come into
worship like supernatural beings or
anything like that we just kind of you
know hang out with other like-minded
people and the best one going right now
be guild war and he is the successor of
anti-seize take it more seriously and
Levay ever and he's a better guest yeah
and he'd probably a really cool guest
he's funny
you can see him you can see him on
YouTube yeah I mean I always felt like
Anton LaVey
like I said I feel like he was doing it
for publicity like he was he was very
aware of his own legend and his myths
and things like that and I don't know if
he took it seriously as a vehicle I
don't even think he fizzles
philosophically took it seriously maybe
I don't really get that ever gilmore's
little more serious yesyes as a system
yeah yeah a system and the system that
you could use to trophy yeah had to be
an individual yeah most of us to do it
looks to gives you the ability to have a
certain aesthetic which I can just do
that was a religion for atheists yeah
yeah like I said if you're an atheist
but you still want to kind of have the
experience of putting on some robes and
yeah yeah if you're gonna have a
religion that's really the best one to
have cuz you're not like telling other
people oh
this is similar to with the Church of
the Spaghetti Monster yeah it's pretty
much like that
but with a harder issue but yeah so
there's also and like I said so Satanic
temple that's a different thing but then
there's also the temple of set yeah
Makena and that was started by Michael
Aquino who was who was in the Church of
Satan for a long time yeah he was a
military officer - he was yeah and he
was on that Geraldo show in the eighties
that rise he almost kind of looks like
the kid from children of the corn Isaac
Isaac Isaac into his head and Spock yen
Spock combined he was had a cool
aesthetic yeah he's a weird-looking dude
but he was like a cool looking and he
was another one of those very serious
once yeah and the temple of said is
still going even though they probably
only have maximum five hundred members
yeah what was great about this during
the Satanic panic that had mom Geraldo
and they were just people would say
these ridiculous things and he'd just be
sitting there you know what are you guys
talking about
they're there you know well I think that
he actually I you know I'm not gonna say
he was responsible for like ending this
a taper or anything like that but he's
one of factors he was one of the factors
because he would go on all these shows
and he didn't get upset
he just stayed very calm he stayed very
rational and he just you know calmly
explained why all these things that they
were accusing people of yeah or are
there unfounded because there's no
evidence yeah which is true there wasn't
yeah he kind of the wind up the sails
yeah you know and a lot of the talk
shows in the 80s and stuff like that I
think I mean they're just spectacle
right yeah you know bread and circuses
so I think that the people that were
audiences on that particularly show
about satanic panic I think they were
kind of expecting the panelists to be
these kind of like wild-eyed like
Charles Manson type medical where
there's like yeah keno would show up and
he's basically Spock yeah and he was a
veteran he was you know and he was a
very educated yeah I think he was a
major I think yeah he might have been
let me see
major or lieutenant colonel yeah
something like that yeah and he was a
high-ranking military officer oh yeah so
Anton LaVey he died in 1997 yeah
there was actually Blanche Barton who
was his girlfriend or wife when he died
she wrote a book about him in nights
like a biography of him in 1990 called
the secret life of a Satanist yeah I'd
be kind of curious too now she's still
in the Church of Satan she's the High
Priestess I believe so she's still
sympathetic about him but you know later
on I think most of the stuff that came
out about him later on was mostly just
that he had made a bunch of stuff up
which he never denied right I don't know
what are your feelings overall about
Anton LaVey before we wrap everything up
I think there's a music guy yeah more
than anything just well I think he was
the right guy the right time to do what
he did yeah he was trying monopolize on
certain forces that were happening in
society do you think he was kind of
responsible for the mainstreaming of the
occult that sort of came out later in
the culture like look at all the Satanic
movies that came out in the 70s and
stuff like that maybe yeah yeah there
was a cult stuff going on anyway sure
most of the occult stuff that was going
on that was kind of what you'd call you
know like this little self-help groups
and how to get in touch with your spirit
remember that remember that show that we
saw about the cult the fake guy who was
having sex with velopment
oh yeah documentary but no I can't
remember his name I didn't know you were
gonna forget oh that was a good that was
that's a good example of what was common
was it it wasn't children of God that
was somebody else that was that was the
flirty fishing and all that kinda
because we did a show about that all
right so we're getting to the end of the
show so we better wrap it up before we
talk about this all this and we have
some more hurricane prep to do plus
another movie review that we got yeah so
remember if you like the show please
subscribe to our YouTube channel
subscribe to 13 o'clock in minutes like
us on facebook follow us on twitter yeah
and you guys got to excuse us for this
show it's very disjointed because we
have they had a largest hurricane
you guys should be glad we're even doing
this fixing that damn generator well if
we're not okay then we're not okay we'll
just figure these black magic to keep
the house that's what I mean this is why
we're good it's good that we're doing a
show on anti my very we're invoking your
a satanic the cornices that's always
cool what I'm gonna say about we meet
that we meet people like that all the
time with the club we do yes that's like
I said I guess in the 60s deal with
today now now we know at least a dozen
yeah you need a guy like that today use
it go
yeah hey hey man yeah you meet them all
the time yeah yeah okay so and don't
forget to check out our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast and also if you don't want to do
a monthly donation then like I said on
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
WordPress com
there is a link just right on the little
side thing there that says PayPal and
you can make a one-time donation to pay
about if you would like to do that that
would be really cool and that'll do it
for episode 56 about a on the bay yeah
buy some shirts to buy some shirts yeah
sure yeah I put new ones up I put a
caddis bathroo yeah I'm wearing one
right now you are yeah yeah well I had
to update a bunch of our old designs
because yeah yeah okay good because
their project entertainment if so but
all the shirts shirts have been updated
and there are a couple new ones up so go
check them out because they're pretty
cool and that'll do it for episode 56 I
think I already said that
yeah whatever and hopefully we don't get
blown away yeah look I'm looking at that
but signing off maybe for the last time
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't ever did
alright so we'll see you guys next
Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you